s work worm
bandcamp to do is eye-fi moderno regents
keep our surfing piece blue
cure
maybe 71 years ago I got severely [ __ ]
ramen in the atmosphere is called the original Toyama black
Ai
true Duma Renna  Well, it's called a Chinese soba bar
Toyama Black is something that locals don't really say
Press bob Grandpa Daybag 9 Chin Polysum and Mumei Aoki-Mr.
A barb female are you doing Water za
There was an air raid, and the
surrounding area was also a burnt field.At that time, there weren't many supplies to eat
.
First of all, I think it's
because the color is
really black.  I think
hde one g sidearm barklamen half-tiger universe Toyama
voodoo I think reala who do
I think it's a ramen with a very rare visual at the time I think the
first impression is important After all
My Toyama Black's characteristics  In other words, the color looks dark. It
looks salty, but it's actually very mild.
Basically, everything comes out.
105 Soup and Charlie's power are all this can you do
Toyama Black is
something I invented.  Well, actually, I don't think so, but
Toyama Black made Popo to become famous in Japan,
so I think this is the most important step.
[Music]